and it will be sean manaya on the mound
for the athletics success against the
indians yes he's 3-0 however last start
four years to the day
2017 for sean manaya so owen fourth last
four starts forget about those numbers
but here's the pitch now swung out at
mess fastball away hernandez strikes out
and that's the way our ball game begins
this one is lofted towards shallow
center
ramon laureano in and he makes the catch
and that'll do it very nice inning for
sean monae to open up the ball game and
young man facing the athletics for the
first time eli morgan and the young man
making the start and maybe he would love
to have seen those win conditions that
lair put up because it's supposedly gale
force wins when he made his debut at
progressive field in downtown cleveland
but relies on a fastball not really that
hard thrown and a good change up
up the middle
goes into a slide can't get it and
that's a one out base hit for elvis
andrews here in the bottom of the first
that's hit well
but it's going to hang up and it's
caught by bradley zimmer
and the inning is over now runs a hit
one left
no score after one
[Applause]
tops it
and
he kicked it couldn't come up with it
that's the perfect place to hit it
an end is
what a play should be a double play
[Applause]
zimmer was taken off and that's a double
plug
wow you will not find a better play to
this i'm sorry this is just outstanding
ball hooking away from elvis anders from
his knees doubles off zimmer at second
base that is a run saver because zimmer
thought the ball was going through he's
actually looking back at other sanders
almost like
wondering is it going to go through and
yeah i agree sean a huge wow
whole bunch of wilds
left center field basic for elvis
anderson for two
both hits for the a's belong to elvis
sanders and here's matt olsen
one shot ramirez back and it's over his
head hangs off the wall and rolls away
elvis anders is being waved home elvis
anders is going to score
so matt olson smokes one off the right
field wall
sanders hustles around the score to give
the a's a one nothing
lead little pop-up not gonna be an easy
play hernandez the second baseman a long
run and it's gonna fall in front of the
right fielder ramirez and it's two to
nothing the a's lead
one strike pitch
change up hit hard down the right field
line heading toward the wall and gone
mitch moreland unloads
on eli morgan and that's the a's
advantage it's three nothing
what they've been doing every year kenny
kemp drops him into center field for a
two-out
swing and a miss he struck him out to
end the inning
four case for eli morgan but it's three
nothing open
there's
deep left field
goodbye roberto perez
with his sixth home run of the year
his third home run in his last five
games gets the indians on the board it's
three to one
[Applause]
does the same thing oh are you kidding
me
well ahmed rosario fortunately legs out
an infield hit because that almost was
going to be
one of those highlight reel defensive
plays
and there it is through the right side
of the infield they had to shift on
ahmed rosario burning into third base
and the indians have runners at the
corners with new buddy out
right back up the middle and through and
the indians cut the game into a one-run
affair and all the way to third with the
tying run is jose ramirez
fran mill reyes rbi number 39.
high fly ball
is it deep enough though let's see
tagging here comes jose ramirez and he
scores easily
and we've got a 3-3 ball game here in
inning number six harold ramirez with
rbi number 23.
[Applause]
high-flying ball deep center field
loriado back he's out of room inside of
here
bradley zimmer his first home run of the
year puts the indians on top
four to three
oh the don has come back home and gone
deep in oakland
that one is drilled right center field
nobody's going to get it
hits off the base of the wall
matt olson is going to have his second
double and his third hit time run is at
second with one out
that's gonna be a base hit left field
here comes mercado he scoops it up olsen
trying and no olson's gonna stop would
throw in the air right to the catcher
perez and matt olsen put the brakes on
and the bases are loaded for moreland
strike three called on a delayed call
got him looking oh he took a fastball
right down the pike and the inning is
over
brian shaw pulls the rabbit out of the
head and the oakland a's leave him
loaded the bottom of the ninth he's down
a run see if they can
grab some lengthening magic manual class
a is
the closer for the indians three and
four 1.72 era he's got 11 saves
well pretty good chance you're going to
get a fast bro guys what do you think
it's a basic right field
100 miles an hour out over the play now
this andrew is just saying he's going to
lay the bat out there
and he's got his third hit and here come
the knees in the bottom of the leg and
these have a start and the tight run is
on facebook and quickly one out that'll
bring up lowry
right field
that baby is gone
lowry has walked it off against emmanuel
clase what a way to start the second
half
one swing in the bottom of the ninth in
the first game back after the all-star
break
lowry wins it for the a's